National Grid has today launched its
scheme to reward customers for using
less energy at peak times with those
households that use Smart Meters
eligible for discounts if they cut their
usage between five and six pm here to
tell us how that will work is Craig
daiku's head of national control at the
company hello to you thanks for joining
us on the program so you have to have a
smart meter then what happens
so the basic premise is you have a smart
meter installed at home and we if you're
a signature to one of 26 suppliers you
can make contact with is a player and
they'll be able to issue with an
instruction today requesting that you
reduce the amount of demand you're
taking at home between the hours of five
o'clock and six o'clock what that means
is you'll get rewarded for that so it'll
be a small payment me towards you for
doing simple things such as moving a
washing machine load to later in the day
or even cooking your tea either earlier
or later that evening
are you asking people to reduce their
energy because you fear a blackout
no that's not necessarily the case so
right through the weekend even going
past back to last summer we put in place
contingency Arrangements recognizing
this wind it was unprecedented with what
was going on in Ukraine but also how the
weather might turn out what we've seen
since last week is the wind has been
extremely cold as a result of that wind
output isn't where it normally is
therefore over the weekend we saw there
would be a tight margin today so we took
the decision over the weekend to warm
three Coal fire power stations just for
contingency so not to necessarily to run
just to ensure that as we get through
the evening Pick today we can ensure
society that there will be electricity
for them to use when they want to use it
well if you're not worried about
blackouts why why bother doing this
so this is all about uh consumer choice
this is all about the first step into
much bigger picture as we move forward
towards net zero so as we all start to
move the way we work and live so with
the phone move into electric vehicles or
using heat pumps we're all going to
require some more flexibility in how we
use our load when we use our load and
also how we get rewarded to use our load
so this is a world leading example of
how we've put together in a short space
of time a demand flexibility service
that allows consumers to shift their
demand and actually get rewarded for it
so this isn't just the end to do this is
the start of something much much bigger
a lot of people though don't want to
have Smart Meters for all sorts of
reasons and you can't get involved
unless you've got one
yeah that's correct and optimism is
about consumer choice so this isn't
about telling people what to do or
telling people how to do it it's for
those who want to get involved who want
to have that opportunity to actually
make a little bit of money but by doing
simple things you'll do every day at a
different time of day overnight as a
result of that it means that they will
get that little reward that goes through
and help them with their bills through
this winter
okay but you're not asking people to
turn their thermostats down are you
now this is about shifting electricity
load away from the peak today so this
about their choice they should do what
they believe is right for them and if
they don't think it's right for them
they don't have to do anything so again
if they are interested I would encourage
them to speak to their supplier and find
out if they can get involved if they're
not already
um okay and if people do want to have a
smart meter how do they get one
contact your supplier ensure you can get
on the list and make sure you get one
installed this year I only have mine for
three or four weeks three or four months
ago and for me certainly even though I'm
in the energy industry it is such an eye
opener so when you use energy through
the day from being that's all about
using an air frames for example so this
is all about getting the consumer
engagement really understanding their
energy choice and also about ensure we
can get rewarded for when they choose to
use it through things as demand
flexibility service but just to
underline if you have a smart meter then
you can be cut off can't you quite
easily
that's not necessarily the case the
smart meter is just about providing
information back to supplier to
understand your recording so understand
the electricity use on any particular
day it's all about the consumer fully
understanding how much energy we use
within a day and across a week and
across a year so they can make informed
choices about where they use their
energy and actually when it comes to it
should they switch the player to get a
better deal
okay good to talk to you thanks for
taking the time much appreciated thank
you